yes i said that what we take for granted
that the inside and the outside are the
same
thing these things when will be
assimilated by the larger culture
and things like uh you know human
machine interface and the ego
identification with the body i think all
these things are going to be
obviated that you see we don't know what
man
is and we have a strong association that
humanness is related to the monkey body
but yet our whole historical career has
been
of projecting ideas into technical
uh accretions and now that we have
computers and things which
mimic intelligence we are beginning to
explore you know what is
humanness ontologically that's what
people are really talking about when
they say can machines think will
machines think
they mean is what we have
focused in on as the defining factor of
our being that sets
us apart from all other things something
which we could manufacture
and the answer is probably to some
degree yes because much of what
is intelligence or appears superficially
to be intelligence
is simply data and retrieval
so that you know more and more of the
culture
is being hardwired into an electronic
coral reef that is simply the outermost
of each of our own exoskeletons
we all have telephones in our homes many
of us have computer terminals
these things introduce us to a global
skin
of information that as the
hardware grows more and more unobtrusive
we will more and more come to identify
these things with our own ego
and we won't even realize that we're
being charged
for thinking about certain questions
because we're actually accessing a
database
somewhere which is feeding us data
so that the commonality of mind
is i think going to be it's somehow the
the triumph of socialism will be the
commonality of mind in a capitalist
context that there really will be an
ocean of thought that you will swim in
and that will be composed of deeper and
deeper
levels of integrated information perhaps
this
is all that hyperspace is is the
entirely expressed informational
ghost of this physical universe
and that it's in the it's in the
informational reconstruction
of the physical universe that the mind
will eventually come to
swim like a fish you know and will come
and go
from various constellations of
aggregation
and integration i mean you see what's
going to happen
is that the rules of the imagination are
going to replace
physics so that we are going to be
able to do and be whatever we can
imagine
well none of us have probably ever put
in much
thought to what would i be if i could be
anything
i could imagine and just 20 minutes of
that meditation
will lead you into pretty strange places
so what would it be like if a culture
evolved for a thousand years
in that way i mean if you could be
anything we all
i guess the first step everyone takes is
they imagine themselves
as the flying saucer the lenticular
mind object made of light that can move
at any speed
and become any object and answer any
question
and no
it's an archetype of wholeness in jung
in his flying saucer book
talked about this thing in alchemy
called the rotundum
which was the thing which spins you know
and it it it's also an alchemy called
the scintilla
the spark and it's
simply because it's round and spins it's
a symbol of wholeness but it's like
the exteriorization of the human soul
the realization that you know
expressing what is within us
may culturally eventually mean actually
exteriorizing the human soul
and interiorizing the human body so that
this world is traded in for the
imagination
and this is sort of what art has always
been trying to do
but we're talking about a breakthrough
in ways and means
on such a scale that you can just march
off into this art
you